[music playing]
James, Paul, congratulations.
You guys have made it to
the third and final round
of this competition.
Now, when you came here,
we threw a little twisted
Damascus challenge at you.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
Ready to see it?
Yeah.
Sure.
All right, that weapon is--
the darb sri gun chai.
I have never seen
anything like this.
I can't even pronounce
the name of this thing.
"Doob-tree goo-trabi?"
What did he say?
Good luck, gentlemen.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, man.
Good luck.
[music playing]
Day one, I'm ready
to get hammering.
I'm going to be using 80CrV2.
It's a very good steel for
impact and edge retention.
And I believe the
tests that they're
going to be putting
this blade through,
it's going to need a
little bit of both.
This is a big chunk
of steel, so it's
going to take a minute to
get the tip forged down
to where I want it
before I can start
drawing it out to the length.
[music playing]
The thing I'm
struggling with the most
is the weight of
this entire blade.
I'm having trouble keeping
this thing straight
when I take it out of the forge.
It's the end of day one.
Pretty happy with the
progress-- got it all drawn out.
I'm ready for a bath, and
get started on this thing
first thing in the morning.
[music playing]
PAUL: It's day one here at my
shop in Fairfield, Connecticut.
And I'm going to be making
a darb sri gun chai.
For this challenge, I'm going
to be making ladder pattern
Damascus, because it's
really going to set
me apart from the competition.
This is 15N20, that's the 1084.
I got to make sure there's
no grease or oil on them,
because that could
affect the forge weld.
After I get the
steel cleaned up,
I stack all the
pieces up together
and do my initial weld.
I'm feeling really good
that the welds have stock.
That's one of the most difficult
parts of the entire process.
The next step is to grind
in notches all along
the entire thing on both sides.
And what that's
going to do is expose
the layers of the Damascus.
It's the end of day one,
and I'm in pretty good shape
for the rest of the challenge.
[music playing]
Pretty nervous today--
we're going to do this
heat treat this morning.
I'm only halfway
through with the time.
So hopefully, if
something does happen,
I've got time to
make another one.
Look at that-- four leaf
clover, right at my feet.
I hope it's a good sign.
[music playing]
I didn't feel any pings or pops.
I'm happy.
[music playing]
It's the last day,
and it's about time
to start etching the blade.
This is the most magical
moment of making Damascus,
because you get to finally
see what the pattern's
going to look like.
I'm still getting
streaks, though.
I don't get it.
It's just not at all
what I wanted to see.
There's a bunch of decarb all
over the entire blade, which
means I didn't
grind deep enough,
and the etch is not
going to come out right.
So I could either
leave the decarb,
and the Damascus just
won't be as good-looking,
or I could grind into
the blade a little bit
and risk making
the blade too thin.
[music playing]
I knew in order to
save the pattern,
I really had to just
go back to the grinder.
And I think it's pretty good.
This is the Damascus
I wanted to see.
I'm still kind of
concerned that the blade is
a little on the thinner side.
But there's nothing
I can do now.
[music playing]
JAMES: Here comes the light
at the end of the tunnel.
So far, I've got the blade done.
So I'm going to start
working on the handle.
I don't have long enough
drill bits to drill
all the way into that handle.
So I'm going to have to
carve out a channel for that
tang to sit in, and
make sure the wood
marries back together nicely.
Yeah, baby.
Made it a little of my
own by adding some fur
from the land around my house.
I think that's going to
add a little special touch.
It is a little on
the heavy side,
but it's balanced perfectly.
It's very wieldable.
I'd say, yeah.
All I can tell you is
grab it by the rabbit.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
Your darb sri gun chais
look intimidating.
But are they deadly?
To find that out, I
will take your weapon,
deliver some killing blows
to this ballistics dummy.
James, you're up first.
You ready for this?
There's nothing I
can do to stop it.
All right, let's do it.
[music playing]
To say I'm nervous right
now is an understatement.
At this point, it's
out of my hands.
I just hope it can hold up.
[music playing]
All right, James--
first up, that's a beast.
It's very forward heavy, so it
definitely feels like a chopper
all the way through.
Now, your handle here-- by
adding this fur around it,
I can't get a good grip on
it because it's so soft.
Now, your edge is sharp.
Overall, sir, it'll kill.
Thank you.
All right, Paul, your turn.
So are you ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
PAUL: I built my blade
to be very light.
It definitely makes me nervous
seeing the ballistics dummy,
because I know there's a
lot of hard bones in there.
And I'm definitely a little
bit worried that it could bend,
even break in half.
You never know what's
going to happen.
[music playing]
All right, Paul--
first up, I really appreciate
the Damascus pattern
that you brought out here.
Now, the fact that I
can hold the weapon out
extended like this shows
just how light this weapon
is for its size.
And because of that, I
can cut deeply into this
without using the weight,
just velocity alone.
But after that strike
through the skull,
it's picked up a
little bit of a bend.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, gentlemen,
to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades,
I'll be chopping
into these pots.
Now, remember, this
is not about what
your blades do to the
targets, but what the targets
can do to your blades.
James, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Let it happen.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
Phew.
This is a
shoulder-ripping monster.
Once you start this
thing moving, stopping it
is really rough
on the shoulders.
The fur around the middle here--
it's a neat look, but
it's very slick, actually.
And then your edge
is still sharp.
You nailed it.
Good job.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, Paul, you're up.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
PAUL: I see the pots,
and I'm very worried.
I feel like it
could bend my blade
even more than it already is.
If something goes wrong,
then I'm finished.
[music playing]
(WHISPERING) Good job, dude.
(WHISPERING) Thanks.
DAVID BAKER: All right,
Paul-- right off, this weapon
has a feel that is excellent.
I can literally use
it with one hand.
The edge-- still sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, bladesmiths, to
see how sharp your weapons are,
I will try to cut
through these pineapples.
James, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Let's go.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[music playing]
(WHISPERING) Nice.
Nice job.
(WHISPERING) Thanks.
All right, James--
just a little off the top.
Your edge is sharp,
cuts cleanly all the way
through these pineapples.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Paul, your turn.
Ready?
Yep.
[music playing]
There you go, man.
Gosh.
[music playing]
All right, Paul,
it is razor sharp.
Just the thinness
of your metal here
cuts through, no resistance.
If you look at the
pineapple heads,
they're all still
standing right there.
It's very sharp.
And more importantly,
it will cut.
Thank you.
[music playing]
James, Paul, you've both done
an incredible amount of work.
However, there can only
be one "Forged in Fire"
champion in this competition.
And that champion is--
Paul.
Congratulations, you're the
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
James, please surrender
your gun chai.
JAMES: Well, I'm pretty
happy I've made it this far.
I don't think I could be too
disappointed in what I've done,
considering how the
weapon performed.
My blade was just
a little too heavy.
Congratulations.
- Great.
You deserve it, buddy.
Good job.
JAMES: It's been a
really great experience.
I did the best I could.
No matter what you do in life,
there's going to be challenges.
And you're not going
to always succeed.
Just get back up, get
back on the horse.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Paul,
congratulations, you're
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Thank you, thank you.
I just couldn't be happier.
This is, like-- got to be
the craziest thing that's
ever happened to me so far.
I mean, I know I'm only 19,
but I still can't believe it.
I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and it feels incredible.
[music playing]